you know I know
that you had a hard time with your
father and
it spanked you and
I just want you to know
it's not gonna happen with me
okay
and I promise I will never spank you
oh
[Music]
we were behind each other in line at the
grocery store and
it was silly but I dropped a can of peas
and he went over to pick them up for me
and
that's where it started
what can I say
it was love at first sight
we've been together ever since
yes she always
has had her own way of doing things
okay
I see what's going on here honey
you don't approve of our engagement no
no sorry sweetheart yes they are like
that
look at the faces
there's no point in trying to raise him
with folks who can't appreciate the
differences in others you should be
ashamed of yourselves
[Music]
honey wait
[Music]
I cannot believe that you would bring a
colored man into our house
foreign
[Music]
it is so good to see you Keith yeah we
usually have to wait for a special
occasion well actually I have a little
surprise I got engaged oh
yes
wow
congratulations little bro
engaged kind of a big deal more for me I
guess that's what that means
yes well um
she got a name Stephanie marriage is a
wonderful Journey 50 on the divorce
sorry bro them's just the facts
I will I will keep that in mind thank
you
you got a photo oh yeah AKA does she
exist there you go
um
oh she's beautiful don't let me get eyes
on this
everybody else already had
great lighting
airbrushed I know she kind of looks like
that one model uh on The Price is Right
uh yes
uh that's her The Price is Right Clive
that's your show shut up mom no it's not
oh yeah
oh yeah Stephanie
people always under bid on their
showcases not the best presenter
where's the wedding oh uh in Hawaii oh
Malachi Maka
has she ever been married before uh no
so she says
ex-boyfriend she got one of course
sloppy seconds at least right Dad
wonderful
mom Silence from you okay you're cut off
from talking
you know what Clive
I really don't appreciate the way that
you're talking to Mom
yes
yes The Prodigal Son hath returned you
know what you want to go let's go cause
I've been here for the last 15 years
taking care of Mom and Dad well you've
been dropping all over the world and why
so you can come back here and criticize
me for how I treat them no
I actually came here
to ask you if you would do me the honor
of being my best man
[Music]
I know that we have a
had our differences
but you're my older brother
we'll pay for your room
and we're also going to rent you a car
and we'll pay to fly you out there
[Music]
first class
well we can't afford first class well
[ __ ]
you you're dead to me
why shut up mom I'm eating in my room
ah
well that uh that went better than
expected
um hi are you Earl peel
who the hell want to know
I think I'm your son
Jordan peel oh okay I see
come on you're here for a minute
close the door on the way in right
all right man go ahead and see if there
I'm gonna explain something to you okay
I had your dad
all right I'm sorry to disappoint you
but that's the situation brother
are you you see what's happening
we're doing the same thing I always do
this I always scratch the back of my
neck like this whenever I'm in an
uncomfortable situation
scratch my neck man everybody scratched
their neck I breathe in and out too man
now everybody my kids okay look at this
that's a picture of me when I was a baby
that's my father
that ain't me
look look man look at that dude's afro
look I got this going on man my hair was
gray he got black hair I mean he
handsome as hell but
I ain't nobody's Daddy
I'm sorry
I've just been looking for him
everywhere yeah yeah show you here since
I got my own TV show now
I don't know I just I know that wherever
he is he he would be proud
yeah you got your own TV show huh yeah
yeah yeah
I'm producing and acting oh you oh you
producing and acting right okay yeah
that's that's my boy
look at that man we're doing the same
thing what is that holy [ __ ] that's
jeans right there man because you can't
do that unless you're sharing mad genes
with somebody it's got to be in your
dnas
thanks for your time you come back home
man I missed you so much
oh hey
when I first came to your door you
wouldn't even ignite
okay okay you know what when I first
came in here stop that
when I first came in here you wouldn't
even acknowledge that I could possibly
be your son but now only after I tell
you that I have my own show on Comedy
Central whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
Comedy Central
get the [ __ ] out of my house
it turns out it wasn't a ghost at all it
was my little sister hiding in the
basement
making the noises the whole time
laughs
oh shoot I forgot his juice boxes oh I
will be right back you'll be all right
with Zach I think so okay
foreign
so
Zachary
you know I'm gonna be marrying your
mother
and uh I'm gonna be moving in soon and I
just
I'm so excited to spend more time with
you
you know I know
that you had a hard time with your
father and
and he spanked you and
I just want you to know
it's not gonna happen but
okay
and I promise I will never
spank you
oh
okay that's
okay
um
I know why you did that
but I will never spank you because I
know that you still oh that's
no
oh yeah
I don't know that there's anything I did
to deserve that oh hey this
you okay
I'm gonna be real with you
you can't go hitting people all right oh
oh oh I ain't coming back for that
fourth one
all right so we done we got that out of
our system because I know
that this
this isn't you
oh I told you you wanna
oh come on thanks
oh what oh that's unbelievable
I'm the good guy I'm
I'm the good guy bam
look
I'm never going to spank you
I'm not going to be like your father
I'm going to be your friend
you need to respect me you understand
you little [ __ ]
I will respect you Charles
if you play your role
now listen up
I'm a bad bad boy Charles
I don't need a [ __ ] friend
so go ahead marry my mommy move in
[ __ ] her as hard as you want
just leave me the [ __ ] alone
you do that 11 years from now I'll be
out of the house and we won't have any
problems
you don't
and I
will break you
okay Charles
[Applause]
how are we doing I love it
[Music]